[Musique]
bonjour ravi de vous retrouver pour ce
nouveau numéro de 7,8 échos le magazine
consacré à l'actualité économique de
notre territoire sans plus tarder voici
le sommaire
nous nous intéresserons aux entreprises
de cinquante ans divine qui se développe
en europe grâce notamment aux fonds
européens
exemple à et long cours avec airbus ou
encore avec émile sort qui s'installera
prochainement à montigny le bretonneux
emmanuel gamme directrice en charge des
financements avant peur à
l'agglomération sera en plateau dans ce
numéro nous ferons également sauf que
sur la société à ce mode est situé à
guyancourt leader des jeux de société en
france l'entreprise pèse plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'euros et
souhaite conquérir le monde
enfin nous ferons un point sur le reste
de l'actualité économique nous
reviendrons notamment sur la candidature
de la france pour l'expo universelle
2025 et les retombées attendues pour
notre région
mais avant de développer tous et y
trouveront ce magazine avec un chiffre à
5,2 millions d'euros cela correspond au
montant total de cofinancement européen
auquel peut prétendre le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines
il faut savoir que depuis l'été 2016
l'agglomération fait partie des quinze
territoire iti en ile de france et y
cela veut dire investissements
territoriale intégrée
c'est un outil qui permet de mobiliser
les fonds européens une réelle
opportunité pour développer un
territoire et c'est ce que nous verrons
d'ailleurs dans quelques minutes avec
est notre invité mais avant si je vous
dis doble ou time's up
cela vous fait sans doute pensé à des
jeux de société que vous avez dans vos
placards et que vous sortez lors de
repas en famille par exemple
eh bien ils ont été imaginés et
développés dans notre région par asmodée
un peloter implantée à un accueil en
cours est depuis plus de 20 ans
l'entreprise n'a cessé de croître et de
se développer à l'international
comme nous allons le voir dans ce
reportage
des cartes représentant une petite
créature jaune chargé d'électricité ou
encore un totem en bois attraper le plus
vite possible
voici deux exemples de jeux qui ont fait
et font encore le succès de là
société blinoise à ce mode est implantée
à guyancourt l'entreprise qui pèse 400
millions d'euros en 2017 emploie plus de
600 personnes à travers le monde avec
une forte présence en europe
aujourd'hui c'est de dix 10 pays
européens dans lequel on est présent les
plus importants angleterre allemagne
belgique espagne italie et puis les pays
nordiques
le tout dernier est en italie c'est le
reste marc celle en cours le plus le
plus solide le plus ancien si le plume
donc plus mature pour nous on va dire
ces trois quarts du chiffre du groupe se
faire entendre sur leur banc depuis plus
de 20 ans à ce mode est distribuée et
édite des jeux de société des jeux de
cartes mais aussi des jeux d'ambiance
comme time's up ou encore perudo très
apprécié d'ailleurs par plusieurs
joueurs de l'équipe de france de
football
un catalogue qui comprend plus de 2000
références et qui fait d'asmodée le
leader des jeux de société en france
son ambition aujourd'hui conquérir le
monde
je vais marais le marché n'a qu en 2006
j'étais parti là bas donc aujourd'hui on
a encore beaucoup de travail à faire là
bas mais on n'a jamais une forte poster
de dévolution une croissance sur les
états unis
on a développé un bureau en chine qui
est un marché émergent sur le jeu un peu
compliqué culturellement et ses
structures de distribution bien
différentes mais on apprend
tranquillement mais sûrement être
innovant trouvait toujours les meilleurs
produits
voilà le secret d'asmodée qui lui a
permis d'afficher une croissance à deux
chiffres ces dernières années ouvrons à
présent notre dossier thématique
consacré à l'europe
en france toutes les trois minutes un
projet est co financée par les fonds
européens des subventions dont profitent
notamment les entreprises de notre
territoire que ce soit des sociétés
européennes comme airbus ou dpm comme
emule sarr reportage numéro un européen
de l'industrie spatiale et de la défense
airbus defence and space est une
division du groupe airbus depuis 2006
le site implanté à elancourt emploie
3000 personnes environ des ingénieurs
qui travaillent pour la plupart sur la
cybersécurité les radiocommunications ou
encore l'électronique de défense
l'entreprise sollicite régulièrement
l'europe pour se développer à l'europe
il y à des taux qui vont de 50 à 100 %
en valeur théorique parce qu'il ya des
modes de calcul qui font que en général
on n'est plus entre 50 et 70 néanmoins
c'est les plus hauts taux qui existent
mise à part les taux de financement sur
les activités de pure défense où on peut
avoir du sens pour cent et récemment le
site saint quentinois pu bénéficier
d'une subvention de 500 mille euros pour
un projet de cyber sécurité
la cyber sécurité une activité qui
représente environ 100 millions d'euros
de chiffre d'affaires et partie entre la
france l'allemagne et l'angleterre
mais l'europe devrait très prochainement
offrir de nouvelles perspectives de
développement pour l encours l'agencé
européenne de défense lance une action
préparatoire de recherche pour une armée
on va dire européennes dans tous les cas
une coalition ce qui nous ouvre une
vraie perspective de collaboration plus
uniquement sur le volet civil mais aussi
sur le volet militaire de nos activités
mais les grandes sociétés ne sont pas
les seuls à pouvoir profiter de l'europe
pour se développer
exemple avec émules sarr dirigée depuis
2004 par frédéric arnault et son frère
installé pour encore quelques semaines à
châtenay malabry
l'entreprise est spécialisée dans la
conception d'ingrédients innovant sous
forme d'émulsion pour être plus concret
l'équipe de frédéric arnaud arrive à
rendre plus légère une mayonnaise ou une
vinaigrette un mélange d'eau et d'huile
utilisés dans l'industrie
agroalimentaire cosmétique et
pharmaceutique afin de développer un
projet dans le domaine de la nutrition
médicale l'entreprise a fait appel à la
commission européenne
nous bénéficions encore d
1016 d'une subvention de la commission à
travers le programme horizon 2020 est
l'instrument p lf
c'est une subvention qui financent 70%
de nos dépenses que ce soit sur lui le
développement de notre projet et son
industrialisation surtout qui s'élève à
un peu plus de 7 millions d'euros sur
sur les deux ans à venir emule sarr
travaille avec des grands groupes comme
l'oréal ou danone
leurs solutions technologiques se
retrouve ainsi sur le marché européen
voire mondial
un savoir faire qui s'exporte et qui
permet à la pm de s'étoffer
une équipe de dix neuf personnes avec un
potentiel d'embauché entre 6 et les dix
personnes dans les deux années à venir
et depuis 2012 nous sommes industriel
mais avec un une croissance qui pour
l'instant n'en était pas encore forte et
donc depuis depuis un an
cette façon s'est accélérée au niveau
justement industriels nous espérons ça
va grâce en partie aux subventions
européennes émules sarr a pu investir
dans un nouveau bâtiment industriel plus
adaptée à son développement
l'emménagement dans les nouveaux locaux
de montigny le bretonneux est prévue en
novembre 2017 et pour approfondir ce
thème
emmanuel gamme a rejoint sur ce plateau
bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes
directrice vous êtes aussi la référente
financements européens au sein de saint
quentin en yvelines
alors on vient de voir dans ce sujet que
grâce aux fonds européens entreprises
émules sar se développer allez même
agrandir son personnel alors est ce que
c'est ça l'objectif premier de ces
subventions finalement favorisé la
création d'activités et l'emploi oui
c'est un des objectifs majeurs de
l'union européenne en matière de
distribution de fonds européens pour le
territoire de saint quentin qui
intéresse un territoire relativement
urbain les objectifs de politique de
cohésion économique sociale et
territoriale est vraiment primordial et
c'est sur ce sujet là en fait que les
fonds structurels peuvent être affectés
à des projets
du territoire alors il existe plusieurs
types de fonds entend parler des fs ed
feder est ce que vous nous en dire plus
et bien justement les fonds structurels
européens c'est le feder et le ffs le
feder c'est le fonds européen de
développement régional et le fse fonds
social européen qui sont deux fonds
relativement différents mais très
complémentaires pour financer à la fois
de l'investissement et du fonctionnement
en tout cas d
des actions d'intervention des
des porteurs de projets sur le
territoire alors ces fonds peuvent être
sollicités un par un territoire comme
saint quentin en yvelines depuis
justement un peu plus d'un an
l'agglomération est un territoire iti ça
veut dire quoi it is et investissements
territoriaux intégrer c'est un
dispositif de financement qui est porté
par la région ile de france puisque la
région ile de france est une autorité de
gestion comme comme on dit et parmi les
quinze territoires d'ile-de-france et
saint quentin a été sélectionné en 2016
donc à ce titre ses 5,2 millions d'euros
qui sont à disposition du territoire
pour des projets qui vont permettre de
répondre à des objectifs assez variés
favoriser la création et la reprise
d'entreprise favoriser les dynamiques de
l'inclusion c'est à dire lutter contre
les discriminations l'égalité femme
homme est un axe aussi majeur investir
dans l'éducation les compétences ça veut
dire lutter contre le décrochage
scolaire c'est aussi favoriser
l'employabilité des franciliens point
des saint quentinois
et puis soutenir la transition
énergétique et notamment et ça c'est un
des axes qui est le plus avancé sur la
programmation était à financer de la
rénovation énergétique dans les
bâtiments sociaux dans les logements
sociaux
une dernière question justement c'est
une entreprise implantée donc sur notre
territoire souhaite mobiliser ces fonds
européens
comment ça se passe ainsi de plusieurs
sites internet qui sont à leur
disposition à la alors les fonds
européens sont gérés à la fois pour le
feder par la région intégralement et
puis pour le fse en partie par l'état et
par la région donc en fait il faut aller
sur les sites des deux entités régions
et départements mais les sites vont
s'afficher il ya le www.esker.fr l'art
c'est la chine qui par exemple voilà et
donc sur cette adresse mail ittihad fkih
point fr vous pouvez
poser une question et nous allons
essayer de vous orienter le mieux
possible vers les partenaires financeurs
qui sont à même de supporter votre
projet merci en tout cas emmanuel gamme
pour votre éclairage je remercie la
grogne des routiers contre la loi
travail la candidature de la france pour
l'expo universelle 2025 ou encore
plusieurs centaines de milliers d'euros
de retombées économiques attendues pour
la ryder cup c'est tout de suite dans
l'actualité économique en bresse c'est
fait la france a déposé sa candidature
pour l'expo universelle de 2025
le vote aura lieu en novembre 2018 si le
dossier tricolore est retenu l'événement
aura lieu sur le plateau de saclay
d'importantes retombées économiques sont
attendues pour l'ensemble de notre
région
c'est vrai que l'exposition universelle
à la différence des jeux olympiques
c'est 35 millions de visiteurs sur une
durée de six mois et donc des retombées
économiques qui sont considérables et un
événement qui est portée par
l'investissement privé mais avant de se
projeter en 2025 voici un événement qui
lui est confirmé à 100%
l'édition 2018 de la ryder cup elle aura
lieu dans moins d'un an
du 25 au 30 septembre au golf national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines et
accueillera deux mille cinq cents
journalistes 60000 spectateurs par jour
et près d'un milliard de téléspectateurs
à travers le monde verront les images
des matchs la fédération française de
golf prévoit 150 millions de retombées
économiques directes et devrait donc
profiter à notre territoire
les routiers ne veulent pas des
ordonnances réformant le code du travail
les frais professionnels seraient
notamment remise en cause
à l'appel des syndicats cgt et fo le
dépôt pétrolier de coignières avait été
bloqué par des manifestants le 25
septembre dernier les syndicats laissent
planer la menace d'une grève à partir du
10 octobre
cette émission touche bientôt à sa fin
mais avant voyons ensemble les rendez
vous économiques qui vous attendent
jeudi 5 octobre le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines reçoit la
deuxième
éditions du sky business d une
convention d'affaires qui réunit et aux
grands groupes pme et tpe
il faut s'inscrire sur le www.skype.com
et puis si vous voulez et bien connaître
les clés d'une organisation
administrative efficace pour votre pour
votre entreprise par dont le ski cuba
guyancourt organise un atelier
c'est lundi 16 octobre de 9h30 à 11h30
la participation est gratuite mais il
faut s'inscrire sur le site
www.skype.com voilà c'est la fin de ce
numéro merci de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve mardi 17 octobre pour un
nouveau 7 8 et co consacrée au sky
business day à très bientôt
[Musique]